hi how is everyone today I want to thank
you for inviting me to participate in
the colloquium I've heard about this
recently from honor Keeler of the
international repatriation project and I
my cell phone from a quina so if you're
familiar with Wampanoag territory it's
just east of here in Massachusetts in
Rhode Island and we also had an exile
community out in schaghticoke New York
after King Philip's War in the 17th
century so those are some of the areas
that we're concerned with as a tribe so
in my work for the tribal historic
preservation department we look to
identifying sites that are particularly
archaeologically sensitive that are
sacred sites that are hopeful preferably
can be avoided but of course many times
a lot of developmental pressure in the
East Coast and so there's archaeology
and monitoring and input from the tribe
and bass case scenario you can avoid it
worst case scenario this data collection
and and you know things go on from there
and so I'll read my presentation i.7
minutes is is tough but I think I can do
it so I'm just going to go through it
quickly i'm here today on behalf of the
Wampanoag tribe of Gay Head aquinnah for
our past and future generations
collections review for myself for
traditional native arts led to in-depth
object analysis and museum collections
here and abroad my journey began locally
with a few unidentified pieces to which
not much importance had been assigned I
did a project on 18th century fabric
sash that was supposed to be king
philip's that was an interesting project
and I published very hopeful of hearing
more information about the fabric and I
think it might really be the only one in
existence from those times unfortunately
and I've also done some photo
identification projects and some other
unusual object identification projects
as well in 2007 I received an invitation
to present at the American Indian
workshop resulting in trips to France
Norway and the Czech Republic
inventories that I saw for curiosity
cabinets included descriptions of Flay
tattooed skins of native people
skeletons pipes wampum giving me an
inkling of what I might find however
experiencing the conflict of moving a
native burial to a more convenient spot
during Reconstruction in Massachusetts
or viewing a Maori human head on display
abroad were deeply disturbing yet I am
compelled to be present and witnessed by
a long line of my female Wampanoag
ancestors in traditional native society
women use their unique perspective to
shape society as defined in the word for
woman mattel misis in Wampanoag it means
the one who has the final say unlike the
clan mothers of old we do not have all
the ancestor all the answers excuse me
my nation is confronted by the results
of looting on a massive scale over
centuries and spanning the globe our
free prior informed consent was neither
sought nor given in this matter nowhere
does stealing from Graves buying human
remains or conducting DNA analysis on
our ancestors fit into our traditional
wampa nog ways of being and doing in the
early contact period and when I say that
I know that's really subject to
interpretation but early contact I think
in this context it's about 16th century
maybe early 17th century in the north
east coast so in the early contact
period a native person admitted to being
the one who pointed out a tribal
cemetery after it had been looted by the
newcomers that person was put to death
by the tribe the sachem ticket talbot
lodged formal complaints with the 17th
century Massachusetts Bay Colony after a
great bear skin and other gifts were
stolen from his mother's grave so tribal
protests were not known or tribal
protocols give me were not known or
respected by the outside world today
there is still little thought given to
tribal credos for honoring those who
have passed away we come together in the
aftermath to think of new ways to
properly return return the dead to
mother earth in humility we ask for
guidance on restoring their repose the
way the Creator intended to facilitate a
lasting peace I have gained valuable
insights through contact with non native
peoples who evidence different
files of communication have other
methods of assigning value and give
different weights to native men's and
women's knowledge and responsibilities
as compared to my own Eastern tribal
network on Turtle Island I do think with
more exposure to Native Americans that
the global consciousness is evolving to
more fully include the federal tribal
voice in authenticating our items and
determining the most ethical fate for
sensitive materials the Aquinnah tribe
recognizes the need for identifying and
developing positive professional
relationships with international
repositories facilitated through the
creation of mechanisms including
international laws and memorandums of
agreement a key component in making
these successful is developing an
ability to practice cultural sensitivity
to our tribal beliefs in dealing with
the sacred an employee of the Aquinnah
Wampanoag Historic Preservation Office I
met with honor Keeler about five years
ago at the Association on American
Indian Affairs and her ovid at her
office in Providence Rhode Island we
have benefited from joining the working
group conference calls members of the
tipo department from aquinnah have
contributed insights from a native
perspective providing thank you
providing colonial military context for
the acquisition of Wampanoag remains
funeral objects and ceremonial items
from our Massachusetts and Rhode Island
homelands my tribe received assistance
in tracking wampa nog objects we
attended the AAA IAS first annual
conference on international repatriation
hosted by the Chickasaw Nation and
additionally benefited from consulting
with the working group on international
repatriation about applicable laws and
to hear about precedent set by other
tribes in Indian country indigenous
research research techniques are
distinct and include thoughtful
examination and family oral tradition
and other tribal records they encompass
the spiritual drawing on native
intuition dreams and memory indigenous
research methodology involves the
ability to recognize and speak the
language of cultural symbolism the
identification of our ancestors and
their ceremonial funeral objects is
complex and demanding requiring the
specific expertise only Native American
tribes can bring to the table
thank you